my good friend david recently made a
video on why battlefield 4 is so darn
good and some of you in the comments
were like hold up battlefield 3 was
better and for those who say that i got
you in this video we're going through
why battlefield 3 was the best
battlefield using our rose tinted
glasses and your comments there are just
so many things here like maps the
sandbox destruction and oh man that
glitchy theme song
if you want to join us as we reminisce
our way to battlefield 2042's launch
give us the old thumbs up and subscribe
to the channel let's get to it
the most important place to start here
is who is battlefield 3 the best for
plenty of you found battlefield 3 to be
peak battlefield and generally better
than later games in the series you're
probably someone who started at
battlefield 2 in 2005 and fell in love
with a massive sandbox or started
playing around bad company 2 in 2010
with its more console focused home
destruction and meandering maps these
games were way ahead of their time and
you probably dumped hundreds of hours of
your life into them then you did it all
over again when battlefield 3 came out
in 2011. you might have even started to
get a little burned out on the series
which is totally normal that meant by
the time battlefield 4 rolled around in
2013 your expectations were pretty high
and you were really craving a big leap
in tech visuals and destruction for a
lot of us what we got in battlefield 4
it wasn't bad so much as it just felt
like battlefield 3 plus more than a dlc
but not quite enough to feel like a
worthy sequel it took steps forward in
some areas like gun customization and
big steps back in others like map design
and speaking of battlefield 3's maps
were just more memorable let's start
with the biggest area that battlefield 3
shined as george o put it battlefield 4
may have been good but it wasn't
battlefield 3 damavan peak attacker team
rushgood battlefield 3's lead designer
david goldfarb was the same as bad
company 2 so it's not surprising that
excellent map design came along for the
ride more specifically battlefield 3
managed to find a middle ground between
the meandering maps that would feel like
a journey from bad company and the
larger scale of battlefield 2. it was a
great compromise for both audiences that
at a high level meant freedom to roam
and also matches with good flow and some
pretty great scenarios there are so many
memorable places like that leap off
damavan peak fighting at night on tehran
highway assaulting ship to shore on carg
island and the dlc kept delivering with
kharkhand that apocalyptic aftermath dlc
and the massive bandar desert from
armored kill i mean back to kharkin was
all about pleasing the battlefield 2
crowd and added so many fan favorite
maps many that are still regarded as the
best battlefield maps to this day like
wake island the themes on these maps
were just so strong particularly in rush
mode battlefield 3 used terrain good
spawn placement and fun objectives to
create moments of advantage for one side
or the other there was often this
tipping point in matches where it became
pretty clear who was going to win this
was even true for many of the conquest
maps in contrast battlefield 4 maps
often feel like a never-ending carousel
with players just circling each other
over and over and over until the tickets
run out because on average one side had
a better kd it's often harder to feel
like you made a difference in a
battlefield 4 match than it did from
battlefield 3. and speaking of rush bad
company 2 was a game built around that
mode it excelled at it and battlefield 3
still had some fantastic rush maps but
battlefield 4 was the absolute death of
that mode it just didn't work on those
wide open maps and the mcom station
placement was pretty dull
so let's dig a bit more into the idea of
flow and how verticality was used a bit
different in three versus four so in
battlefield 3 verticality often moved an
attacking team forward around the middle
of the map or gave the defending team a
momentary advantage at the back of a map
so there was less of a chance to be
pushed all the way to their spawn not
that that didn't happen battlefield 3
wasn't perfect people often did get
spawn trapped battlefield 4's vertical
spaces in contrast felt kind of randomly
placed or often just dropped in the
middle of the map in a way that you
couldn't really move anywhere without
getting shot from somewhere we'll talk
about fairness a bit later same with
vehicles battlefield 3 used vehicle
spawns to push teams forward an idea
that it took from battlefield 2 and can
be seen especially in rush but again
even in conquest on battlefield 4's maps
the use and placement of vehicles felt a
bit haphazard like on lan kang dam which
is known for pretty bad flow or most
confusingly when a jet wound up on a
city map dawnbreaker even in a highly
regarded map siege of shanghai the game
just relied on rear vehicle spawns with
a fairly dull capture point in the
middle once the tower came down that
meant rather than pushing forward both
teams tanks continually stalemated at
the middle making for kind of a dull
match
visuals ahead of their time you can't
really talk about maps without talking
about the frostbite engine and what a
massive leap forward battlefield 3 was
for its time we're talking about 2011
here as centric terror 27 put it the
reason why i hold bad company 2 and
battlefield 3 close to my heart is due
to the massive leap that it took with
the frostbite engine or mavhunter 405
who said i think many like me who liked
battlefield 3 over battlefield 4 may be
due to the fact that it brought next
level graphics even to the playstation
3. it marked an era in the future of
next gen graphics battlefield 3 came out
a year after bad company 2. and as much
as i love the bad company series
visually battlefield 3 made significant
progress this decade game looks amazing
now on my 4k monitor it's just so rare
for a game to come out that makes you
realize how much technology has advanced
and what games are suddenly capable of
there's this crispness to battlefield 3
that's a combination of sharp visuals
punchy sound and constant explosions
that's just so immersive
now i'll fully admit for some the
on-screen effects in battlefield 3 felt
like too much
like yeah
that's a lot that was intense lens flare
your eyeballs were dirty or something
and there was this blue tint which
honestly i never personally noticed
until i read about it but it bothered a
lot of people i'll also take that any
day of the week over later battlefield
titles where textures became extremely
muddy and i literally couldn't see enemy
soldiers standing right in front of me
because they just blended into the
background and don't get me started on
those poorly modeled hands in later
battlefield games that are just always
in your view all the time
just
constant heebie-jeebies
destruction as masterdark put it
battlefield 3 with all the expansions
like close quarters is the best
battlefield battlefield bad company 2 is
a close second with the amount of
destructible everything seeing the map
get ripped to pieces over the course of
the game until buildings were just huge
piles of rubble was amazing because
battlefield 3 was a compromise between
bad company and battlefield 2 it did
sacrifice some destruction for scaling
graphics you didn't have maps getting
fully demolished like bad company but
there was still a lot of demolition
going on around you battlefield 3's
destruction made sense it was pretty
clear that most walls could be blown out
except for obvious set pieces like an
oil tower many maps started pretty clean
and ended up demolished it was just so
much fun to watch everything get torn
apart as you went destruction in
battlefield 4 by contrast doesn't feel
like there's a logic to it in many
places you have to remember which walls
the game will let you demolish maps seem
to either mostly swap destruction for
levolution or heavily try to control
what things you can destroy and where
ultimately trading organic destruction
for revolution was a downgrade in my
opinion levolution is fun at first but
then it gets repetitive and some apps
are actually worse after they change i'm
really hoping battlefield 2042 goes back
to letting players blow apart most
things like battlefield 3 did
time to follow up destruction by talking
about guns battlefield 3 feels really
good to play it can be hard to put in
words exactly what the secret sauce is
but this comment on reddit stuck with me
what they said was battlefield 3 was
simplicity and chaos there was a
tightness to the design of everything
that really shows in the gunplay of
battlefield 3. mainly there was just the
right amount of guns and gear for the
maps and modes included or as zeleter
put it battlefield 3 was better felt
more balanced and finished destruction
was better you could destroy a lot of
buildings and external walls just
overall gameplay felt better and i
enjoyed battlefield 3 much more than
battlefield 4. couple things here there
were fewer guns but each had a distinct
personality and they were less friendly
to handle which was a classic
battlefield thing that meant players
needed more skill to use them you really
did need to learn how to tap fire many
of the weapons and often going full auto
just meant missing a lot more
battlefield 3 also had grenades pretty
under control with only one type you
could hold up to two of but they didn't
do a wide area of damage and they were
very situational later titles devolved
into so much grenade spam that going
indoors was flat out not fun unless you
liked being tear gassed smoked set on
fire and fragged all at the same time
battlefield 4 in contrast to three added
a lot more guns a much more extensive
attachment system as well as tons of
grenades and gadgets but more doesn't
mean better and what was lost with all
that stuff was that tight rock paper
scissors design i guess i should
acknowledge suppression in this section
the more i go back and play three the
more i both get why people hate it but
also it's kind of grown on me yes it
goes too far sometimes but it lets you
do things like temporarily suppress a
doorway or put fire on a recon player
and get up close to them before they can
get you i'm not in love with the fact
that suppression seems to pop all the
time but i can live with it and you can
even take perks that reduce its effects
classes with proper guns in their kits
battlefield 3 had a strong sense of
balance between engineer assault support
and recon each had a clear role and you
knew what to expect generally if you
rounded a corner and ran into an assault
player they had a pretty good chance of
winning that 1v1 engineers had a great
cat and mouse game going with tanks
where good tank crews could dominate
with teamwork but good engineers could
drop armor fast and a team on a roll
really did need support around to drop
ammo or pop a bipod and hold down a lane
for a second or two before they got
sniped around battlefield 4 class
weapons started to run together for
example an engineer could use longer
rage carbines and dmrs or recon could
use all-class guns to fight at mid-range
whereas before they were only really
strong at either very long or very short
distances i'm a bit worried we're going
even further in that direction with
specialists in 2042 particularly the
fact that they can all carry rocket
launchers but let's play the beta first
and then see how we feel
dying and fairness told you we'd come
back to this due to good map flow most
of my deaths in battlefield 3 made sense
the spread and recoil of some guns
combined with suppression and generally
small hit markers meant there was a
certain amount of randomness and i did
kill trade plenty but it was almost
never confusing what had just happened
it went downhill hard after battlefield
3 with server issues a terrible kill cam
system and frustrating map design which
meant you were constantly getting shot
in the back or from totally random
directions dying in battlefield 4 when
you thought you'd made it behind cover
and then having the killcam show you
something that looked impossible
happened almost every round i can't
stress enough how frustrating
battlefield's kill cams became after a
three at this stage i'd even take a
classic call of duty version that just
shows you the last few moments of the
person that got you
moments when you put it all together the
maps destruction balance and gun play
battlefield 3 had so many great
battlefield moments you'd look up and
see an attack chopper laying into the
other team or pull off a kill trade with
a tank last minute with a blowtorch as
it ran you over or just any huge number
of things that could happen in a match
sadly i don't have the footage from back
in the day but hardcore mic only servers
were often fantastic with people calling
out the need for a tank to move up and
demolish something or the moment you
rounded that corner spotted an enemy
tank 10 feet away from you and thought
you were totally screwed when out of
nowhere someone on your team with a jet
shouts i got this and top guns there
again some of this comes down to you if
you played battlefield 3 before
battlefield 4 but i don't personally
have as many of those same fond memories
from four if you do have those memories
from battlefield 4 i am not taking those
away from you
campaign plus co-op i'll just throw this
out here i'm not a huge campaign person
and i usually just jump into multiplayer
which is why i'm gonna toss this one to
top gunner 1994. indeed i would say
battlefield 3 is the best battlefield
though many vets who've been playing
longer than me would probably say
battlefield 2. i don't know but anyway
battlefield 4 has better customization
and battlefield 3 has better maps so the
tiebreaker is single player i had a much
better campaign experience on
battlefield 3 than battlefield 4. in
fact battlefield 4's campaign is one of
the worst single-player experiences i've
ever had so battlefield 3 is the winner
i honestly found both battlefield 3 and
battlefield 4's campaigns to be totally
forgettable and neither could hold a
candle to bad company however
battlefield 3 also had co-op which was
fantastic some matchmaking challenges
aside from fighting along a river at
night to defending points in the streets
to that amazing fire from the sky
mission there were so many great
scenarios fire from the sky in
particular both top players had to fly
choppers finally i mean the only other
way was a private server much later on
but also it had bots which at the time
really felt like the future of
battlefield granted bots were in the
original battlefield games like 1942 but
vanished later in the series and now
they're back with 2042 which also
doesn't have a campaign
so these are some of the reasons many of
us consider battlefield 3 to be peak
battlefield and in some of our eyes the
series declined after that point i want
to stress that if battlefield 4 was your
entry point that's awesome i can
absolutely see why that was your
favorite battlefield we're going to keep
looking back at what was great about
different games in the series and it
feels like hardline was misunderstood
might need some love but if there's a
battlefield that didn't get the
recognition you feel it deserved say the
battle snack size 1943 tell us why in
the comments below or maybe you're just
this person who said planetside 2 is the
best battlefield game they're not wrong
we are fast approaching battlefield
2042's release with upcoming betas in
september and the game being out in
october so head on over to gamespot's
youtube page because we're in this
together thanks for watching
[Music]
[Music]
you